[Music]
all right dr. Judd is in the house we're
ready to rock and roll how you feeling
yeah I get super excited to talk to you
you you are like the perfect guest for
this podcast because you occupy this
sweet spot that I don't know anybody if
anybody else can claim where you are
steeped in the hard science
evidence-based science psychiatrist
academic neuroscientist but you're also
equally steeped in the world of
mindfulness like the softer sciences and
all things spiritual at the same time so
this is like the bull's eye of the
things that I'm most interested in and
it's a rare opportunity to talk to
somebody who who stands on equal footing
in both of these worlds usually it's you
know hard scientist or somebody who's
coming from a completely spiritual
perspective and never the twain shall
meet
but but here you are she's a rare
creature well it's been really
interesting to just see how hard these
hard sciences actually are and how soft
these sign itself Sciences actually I
don't think that we like to make
dichotomies in the world that that's one
that really started to fall apart as
I've explored both of them yeah well it
was an interest it's been an interesting
journey for you your entry point into
all of this like I think just to
contextualize what we're gonna talk
about I think that would be interesting
to learn more about sure where do you
want to start well how about with you
know what got you interested in
mindfulness and meditation to begin with
I mean it was sort of precipitated by a
little bit of a relationship crisis
memory serves me yeah that is true you
know I did start meditating my first day
of medical school after going through a
bad relationship breakup but I can look
retrospectively on my life and realize
you know there are a lot of points
earlier in my life where I had touched
on something that I didn't know what it
was but I knew it was really sweet
hmm whether it was you know I raced BMX
bikes when I was a kid and I played
quartet music you know as a group
playing the violin and there was
something about being
in a group of four people and making
music
we're just ever the world dissolved and
we were we were just the music and I
didn't know what that was I just knew
that I was some strange kid in high
school that would rather play quartets
and go out and get drunk you didn't know
that at some point in the future all the
cool kids would be calling this a flow
stage I had no idea and here it is yeah
so I think I touched on it at various
points in my life but it really you know
took something that I was really
devastated by the to kind of precipitate
a big change you know it's starting
medical school to new start in my life
new points so it seemed like a good
place to try something what I thought
was new right why that though other than
like hey I'm in medical school like I'll
get a prescription to help me sleep
better or to calm my nerves yeah I've
never really been you know I'm a
psychiatrist i prescribed medications
but I've never really been in - I've
been pretty careful about putting
medications or any types of drugs in my
body and I really felt that throughout
my life that just really finding good
ways to nourish my mind and body were
the better way to go so you know I
started getting into eating well in
junior high school actually when I was
BMX bike racing I realized you know we'd
raced these three heats in a race you
race over heat and then you'd have to
wait and then race another one so you're
actually competing in BMX yeah yeah Wow
yeah well Indiana there's not a whole
lot else to do what I found you know
what I would I would eat junk food in
between heats and realized that I didn't
much energy to race the second or third
heat and then my mom was like hey why
don't you try eating a peanut butter and
honey sandwich and I was like okay and I
realized you know wow I had to sustained
energy and and I could do much better
and so I started getting into that back
in high school and I was running across
country and track and and wrestling and
realizing that that health food was
actually really helpful performance and
so I think that even extended into when
I started really getting into loving to
explore things scientifically and not
wanting to
put things that might mess up my brain
in my body but psychiatry wasn't the
original plan not at right now so how
did that evolve you know I was so I was
doing this MD ph.d program where I was
studying medicine and I was doing a PhD
in immunology and I got into that
because I was really interested in the
brain mind interaction I was really
fascinated by like why we get sick when
we're stressed out uh-huh and so I was
doing all of this mouse work would make
you know knock out gene knockout genes
and certain cell populations and mice
and see what would happen and that was
really interesting and at the time I was
just you know I was meditating on my own
because I was trying to work with my own
stress and realized that you know by the
time I finished that program you know it
was like eight years into it that I had
learned so much more about the mind from
my own meditation practice than I had
from actually studying mice that I
shifted you know I did this major it was
a seismic shift in my career was like
one of those go big or go home moments
where it was like I'm gonna try
something completely new and study it
cuz nobody really been studying this
stuff at that point to you know to the
safe you know what I could do I could do
science I'd learned to do science but I
really wanted to see how this mind-body
connection really worked on a human
level but it was your experience with
IBS that kind of tipped a scale right
like realizing the that there really is
this mind-body connection that
transcends our typical conventional
Western medicine protocol on how to
treat certain illnesses yeah in college
I had a really severe bout my senior
year of college I'd love to run and and
I I would have to plan my runs around
having a bathroom nearby where I could
stop you know and go to the bathroom if
I need to and I remember going into the
to the doctor at the at the University
and you know saying oh maybe I got
Giardia cuz I did a lot of backpacking
and he said you know could this be
stress I said no this can't be stressed
murdered and I listed like ten things
but the reason why I could not pass away
you kind of shook his head and it's like
well maybe
someday and it took me in a you know a
while to realize that that was actually
my mind that was throwing my body out of
whack and so I study I was studying that
on a molecular level but when I finished
my PhD I wasn't actually satisfied with
the answers that I had discovered in in
graduate school you know one somebody
asked me this question we discovered all
this stuff about the immune system and
whatnot and how stress affects it
somebody said well how do you know
that's true in humans and I said well I
don't know I would have to actually do
this in humans and so that got me
thinking about well you know what do we
know about the mind-body interaction in
humans and how can we actually study
this and I had done some medical school
rotations in psychiatry and started to
see that my patients were actually
talking the same language that the
ancient Buddhists were talking you know
2,500 years ago there was like I'm
craving and clinging in all this stuff
and ice I was thinking you know I don't
think this can be a coincidence it's
really you know there's got to be some
connection here and that's when I
shifted my career to saying okay let's
study mindfulness is a treatment for
addictions as compared to you know
studying these you know these small
molecular pathways in in mice and how is
that received by your peers at the time
I remember distinctly I always it I
would say it's Yale University for my
residency training and and there can be
you know let's just say there can be
some pretense in some folks and some
somebody said you know you're gonna kill
your career you know this is you know
you've done well as a scientist you're
gonna you know you're gonna totally -
everything that you that you've built up
and they people just started distancing
themselves from me and I figured well
I'd rather fail doing something that I
really am passionate about then succeed
and just you know just do science yeah
so just are you one of those people who
when you're told you can't do something
you're you're trying to prove them you
know otherwise yeah that's that's
actually why I went to Princeton was my
college counselor told me I never get in
oh really well you have an interesting
upbringing right like you grew up single
mom you know with with uh if three
siblings yeah where are you guys yeah on
food stamps at one point I think I heard
you say it one you know I think when you
were talking to Dan Harris I listened to
that interview so it's quite it's quite
a trajectory for for you to have you
know going from from that place into
Princeton yes I have a good mom my mom
is amazing yes really you know my hero
she she raised four kids by herself went
to law school at night and we all stayed
out of trouble made it through college
what are your siblings doing my sister
is an emergency medicine doc my brother
works at MIT my older brother does this
value he's a business valuation person
so they're all doing Wow
is your mom still around she is yeah I
should get her on the podcast you know
how to raise I could use a little help
in that department right now
Wow so that's amazing so you know
Princeton you got your your medical
degree at Washington right in st. Louis
yeah and then you're at Yale and now you
seem like you're affiliated with all
kinds of universities I can't keep it I
can't even keep it all straight like
you're you're running institutes at like
brown and MIT and you're doing something
at at Massachusetts General Hospital
well mostly I might at Brown you okay
the director of research and innovation
there in the mindfulness Center right so
where does all of this dovetail into the
world of addiction you know it's on a
very basic level we're probably all
addicted to some degree or another and I
say this not lightly you saying oh
everybody's got addictions but if we
look at this this really comes back to
the most basic learning mechanisms that
are known to man and it's a matter of
you know we're along the spectrum does
it get us into trouble and so
classically we used to think of
addictions you know and and you know
this as much as anybody else you know is
these the substances like alcohol and
cocaine and heroin and whatnot but
really I think that's a little narrow of
view
if we look at this it's it can be
virtually anything that gets us into
trouble you know I really like there's
this very simple definition continued
use despite adverse consequences right I
learned that in residency and that
really stuck with me because it really
defines the scope of the problem where
we can have you have everyday addictions
where it's you know cellphones and
technology and you know trying to get
our inbox to zero and all these things
that are failing propositions well I'm
delighted to hear you say that you've
written extensively on this subject
because I really do believe that there
is a universal theory of addiction that
when broadly defined is is a net that
captures all of us and we tend to think
of you know the drunk in the alley or
the guy who can't pull the needle out of
his arm or somebody who's in jail as a
way of distancing those people from
ourselves and not having to really look
in the mirror but I really think that
that addiction is is is a spectrum
condition and every single person falls
somewhere along those lines so you have
the you know the the hopeless heroin
addict on the far end of that but if
we're all really objectively honest with
our own behaviors we're all habituated
to certain behaviors or activities or
you know the intake of substances that
cause adverse effects in our lives time
and time again and we all sort of have
this sense of powerlessness over our
ability to control it or arrest it yeah
absolutely and it's I'm so glad you
point out that piece because you know
for the last 50 years the dominant
paradigm has been willpower right and
that is proving to be more myth than
muscle you know it's it's more legend
than than reality so it really you know
it's it's fascinating in so many ways
one is you know we have to survive so
that we can be addicted to things like
sugar we're you know we've got to get
calories or we're not gonna survive as
human beings and then you know as humans
we're we're so good at refining material
we've been able to hear in the last
couple of hundred years refined things
like you know tobacco and cocaine you
know coca leaves are not addictive but
you know if you get it into that little
powder yeah that's a whole different
story
Society has done an incredible job of
creating creating pathways and and
products that are specifically designed
to addictive to hook us and not let us
go yeah that's unprecedented in human
history it really is and the more we
learn you know there's this accumulation
of knowledge that just builds on itself
and builds on itself
you know BF Skinner this famous
behaviorist he wrote a novel about this
in 1947 yeah where he basically
predicted he called it behavioral
engineering but he basically predicted
what social media has been able to
really capitalize on in the last couple
of years to just really get us get our
focus so narrowed that we're you know
they have to paint look up on crosswalks
you know in big cities now because
people are forgetting the most basic
survival things like don't cross the
street without looking both ways though
the willpower idea it's it's it's
amazing that it perpetuates I certainly
have up-close and personal experience
with trying to master my many addictions
through willpower to diminishing ends
and as somebody who has always prided
myself on myself well this has been a
confounding you know sort of experiment
that has taken me to some pretty low
depths so I know firsthand that
willpower does not work I think there's
a lot of Education that needs to go into
the public for them to appreciate the
full extent of that but why doesn't it
work yeah well we can dive into that but
some of this piece about education I
think can't just come cognitively you
know we have to you know I I was in the
same boat where it's like I had to learn
that willpower failed on a personal
before I started to let go of it right
and was fortunate that I was actually
studying this stuff at the same time so
instead of saying well why doesn't this
work I could actually explore oh this is
why this doesn't work and it actually
drew me into these avenues of like well
what actually does work so if we if you
want to dive in yeah let's do that
the way I you know the way I think about
this is we have this caveman brain
mm-hmm you know that was really set up
to help us survive we needed we needed
food we needed to reproduce and we
needed to avoid danger you know they eat
and not be eaten thing and it can really
be distilled down into a simple process
of you need a trigger a behavior and a
reward from a brain perspective so if
you see food you eat the food and then
your stomach sends this dopamine signal
to your brain that says remember what
you ate and where you found it now this
reward based learning process is set up
to help us remember things so it
actually the dopamine firing is there to
help us remember something it helps lay
down a memory and often dopamine and
modern day gets associated with pleasure
but we can dive we can put a pin in that
and talk more about that later
not really a whole lot of pleasure in
that agitated frenetic driven got to do
this yeah right and that's that's the
drive to use more when we get addicted
so basic learning process remember where
food is same thing remember we're
dangerous you know you see the
saber-toothed tiger you run away and
then you get to remember okay don't go
back there or I won't get to do that
again so that process it still it plates
the strongest learning mechanism
mechanism that's known in science all
the way evolutionarily conserved all the
way back to the sea slug so really
really well-known process yet in modern
day it's still at play mmm but we have
availability of food 24/7 right we all
have refrigerators there you can you can
find a diner a restaurant that's open at
any time day or night you can get food
delivered and he taught day or night so
we don't really need to remember where
food is anymore we just need to remember
our phone is and we can order it yet our
brains still Sanwa
you know I'm I'm taking up a whole lot
of real estate for this learning
mechanism so let's use it and so we
start to learn to do things like eat
when we're stressed or anxious not when
we're hungry you know and this splits
out hedonic vs. homeostatic hunger
you know the homeostatic hunger is like
when we're actually hungry the hedonic
is based on emotions and based on stress
and things like that we learn to take
pills when we are emotionally or
physically in pain as compared to
learning you know to deal with it you
know social media is engineered for the
the likes and the retweets
so yeah it's it extrapolates out even to
things like that are as as a nerd is
boredom you know it doesn't have to be
this sense of disease or some kind of
emotional discomfort or or or something
that triggers an uncomfortable memory it
can be as banal as standing in line at
the grocery store yep yeah I don't know
if you've ever pulled up to a stoplight
late at night and you look around and
everybody's crotch is glowing no it's
like suddenly 30 seconds at a red light
is intolerable right well we only got
there because we've let ourselves get
there and we can say oh I'm not gonna do
that you know I'm gonna be a good boy
and and willpower my way way through
this forget about it you know like you
said it that doesn't work so let's get
into why it doesn't like why is it that
I can't override that impulse and
through sheer force of will like
Marshall my mental and emotional powers
to prevent myself from doing that thing
that I am so lured - yeah it sounds
pretty good doesn't it you know we're
these rational thinking beings I think
Descartes really sent us down a path
that's not so good you know oh I'm
thinking therefore I can think my way
through stuff it's not how our brains
were yeah you know the there's a part of
the brain the prefrontal cortex that
that's involved in in willpower it's the
weakest part of the brain from an
evolutionary perspective it's the first
that goes offline when we're stressed
when were angry when we're sad when
we're tired you know that's why we
wander into the kitchen late at night
looking for something because we're you
know
we've we've learned that and so we can
say don't do that but then we just crash
harder you know and in the morning we
set that resolve to like okay I'm really
gonna do it this time
but that's just not how our brains work
our brains don't don't work that way but
we think you know I think it's more of a
rationalizing you know willpower it must
be something let's study it and there
you know there's been a little bit of
this and that but it turns out that
willpower if you look at the people you
know that quote/unquote have good
willpower habits there there's some
really interesting pieces there one is
they actually find things that they
enjoy doing so people you know people do
something like eat healthy or exercise
if you ask them why they do it the
people that are really good at doing it
and you probably know this personally it
feels good as compared to oh I need to
get in shape to get a you know my body
looking this way for the bridge not like
an intellectual exercise not at all
and that that part makes sense but
that's not willpower and it makes sense
because that is real work based learning
we're doing something out of the reward
of doing it not because we're doing it
so that's one of the big misconceptions
around willpower is that if you look at
reward based learning it's based on the
reward it's not based on the behavior
itself so if it were the behavior we
just say stop doing this but it's
actually the reward that drives future
behavior and that's where we can start
to intervene how does it correlate with
intelligence because just speaking from
personal experience I've noticed over
the years through my adventures and
journeys in the in the recovery
community that people who are hyper
intelligent often struggle the most
because they want to intellectualize
this we're truly it is an emotional
thing more than anything else and so
they struggle trying to wrap their heads
around how to do this and they can't let
go of the idea that that that solution
resides within the mind yeah well so hi
my name is Judd and I might I'm a
thinking addict there he go if you look
at the bookshelves in my house
they are way too numerous so speaking
from personal experience and I think
this this applies is there's this it's
almost like the thinking part of our
brain is kind of like this it's like
it's like refined sugar or refined
carbohydrates it actually just gets us
stoked like oh that's interesting
I'm just gonna learn more and I'm gonna
learn more and I'm gonna figure out the
solution to this thing meanwhile day
after day after day you're perpetuating
the same behaviors unknowingly yeah I
know you're buying every self-help book
yeah so what we really need is to land
in our body because our body is really
really wise and so this is you know this
intellectual thing is like you know it's
it's that it just drives more addiction
where it's like I want to learn more as
compared to really landing on our direct
experience that says you know dude why
would you do that I'll give you an
example so with we did a study with with
people who are trying to quit smoking
and we randomized people to get
cognitive therapy or mindfulness
training where we train them to really
just pay attention to the results of
their behavior so when they come into
the mindfulness group they don't even
know what they're getting you know so
they come in they're like I'm here to
quit smoking and I say okay next when
you go home smoke and they're looking at
me like is this the experiment you're
running is this the study I say no smoke
but pay attention as you smoke and see
what happens so they pay attention to
the smell to the taste to the feeling of
the superheated smoke going into their
lungs and they come back and they're
this mister yuck look on their face
they're like oh my god how about I never
noticed that before because they
realized that smoking tastes like [ __ ]
and they can only get that wisdom from
their direct experience I had a guy who
said we in our first study we we first
class was on Monday second class was on
Thursday this guy was smoking thirty
cigarettes a day
he'd been smoking that for a long time
he came back on Thursday and he said
yeah I'm down to ten cigarettes and I
said well what happened and he said well
I noticed that I would drink coffee and
the coffee was kind of bitter so I'd
smoke a cigarette to numb my
from the taste because it's amazing how
smoking numbs your taste and so he
realized well I don't need to smoke I
could brush my teeth and he just went
through this litany of 20 cigarettes
where they were all he was smoking all
these things out of habit where he'd you
know he'd learned through this reward
based learning process that oh if I
smoke I feel better you know whatever
this was this is not a good way to go so
the idea being you talk about this in
your book is diverging from what Skinner
calls the operant conditioning right
which is behaviorism yes traditional
approach to like dealing with these
kinds of problems to a more Buddhist
perspective which you call or is called
dependent origination right and this
involves being present for the
experience and rather than getting into
judgment self judgment to just be
curious about what's happening yeah
absolutely and it's interesting so one
of the one of the first aha moments for
us in my you know my research career was
when I was looking on studying this
operant conditioning or positive
negative reinforcement and I was
thinking wait a minute this sounds way
too familiar and I started looking into
this because I've learned you know I on
a retreat or something I've learned this
this dependent origination piece and it
was kind of you know complex or these
twelve steps and all this stuff about
birth and this sounds like well what is
this but when I looked at it and I
actually worked with a Pali scholar
to really explore this it turns out that
dependent origination explains operant
conditioning and so the Buddha
psychologists had figured this out 2,500
years ago before paper was even invented
and so they were describing the same
process and importantly this process
depend or generation was what reportedly
the Buddha was contemplating on the
night of his enlightenment as in hey pay
attention guys this is kind of important
so really important concept that
actually is rediscovered in modern day
and drives you know and explains a lot
of how addictive behavior is formed and
that concept is what distilled down
basically that trigger behavior reward
so I
you know you see something you eat
something and and you you get some
reward or you you know let's use your
boredom example we're sitting here bored
and so our brain says oh why don't you
look for cute pictures of puppies on
Instagram or something like that so we
look at those cute pictures of puppies
and we don't know that we're actually
just driving that escape from boredom
process and so so that's basically it
and it's interesting in ancient times
they said that the process is
perpetuated through ignorance but in
modern day we call that subjective bias
because we become biased based on our
previous behaviors so if I learn to eat
you know eat some junk food when I'm
bored or when I'm sad or when I'm lonely
I'm actually driving that process where
I start to navigate my world in that
biased manner where I'm you know it's
like any little hint of boredom my brain
says oh have something sweet have
something sweet or you get to keep
pictures of puppies on Instagram or
whatever but doesn't that butt up
against the countervailing impulse to
avoid those things based on past
negative experiences with them like how
do those those things cry I mean I'm
just thinking out loud about like what
my own personal interior experience with
this kind of thing is which is I'm
self-aware enough and I've done enough
internal work to to be conscious
cognizant when this is when this is
happening right it's like okay yeah I
know I'm pissed off at this guy and I
know I'm feeling like not really in my
body and I know that this thing is gonna
fix it and I know I shouldn't do it and
then I do it and I have a moment of
relief followed by you know an avalanche
of shame that sends me into a spiral for
the next 48 hours I'll need to be
repeated again with a sense of powerless
yes so that's self awareness as they say
in in you know in in the secret society
of which I am a member
self awareness or you know will avail
you nothing in this so I'm interested in
how like we have this you know this this
reward mechanism cycle that you just
described on the other side I have self
awareness that this is occurring in real
I'm powerlessness to stop it without you
know the brake you know as I surmise
from from your work is really letting go
of trying to control it and just being
allowed being in the allowing like being
in the present right am I getting that
right I mean I've thrown a bunch of
ideas at you you are and they're already
make sense that's the second step I
would say or maybe even the partner so
just wake up a little bit so it's you're
talking about there there we go
cool so the first and I think you've
nailed the critic critical element which
is awareness but like you're pointing
out awareness doesn't do it by itself
and can actually perpetuate the process
so if we don't know how our minds work
we can't work with them and if we're if
we're aware that something is causing us
pain we might just spiral into another
habit leap of shame and guilt and all
that stuff so the first the first piece
here is really understanding how our
minds work if we can see that we're
driven by these processes and we can
even entertain the possibility of
willpower failing which you know often
it's it's tough to say
oh it's its willpower that's failing me
as compared to that was a dead on
arrival process you know it all the diet
programs want us to think that you know
willpower is the way to go and if we're
just not strong enough we need to just
sign up for another year and then maybe
we'll get it next year or the extra
special behind the velvet rope vit
program that only I will wait only for
you yeah if you can pay the admission
fee so the first step is really
understanding how our minds work and
we've actually shifted our programs to
training people in that step first it's
really you know it's pretty
straightforward like we're talking about
they're there no there's no secret
behind the behind the curtain thing to
reward based learning it's like you
identify your triggers you see your
habitual behaviors and then most
importantly you pay attention to the
rewards or the results and so that's
where awareness actually can become it
it can become our friend rather than
something that just spirals us into
shame and self-doubt and the key there
is again
looking at the reward because that's
what drives behavior so for example with
the example of the guy that was smoking
he started to see that smoking actually
tasted pretty crappy and so his brain
started to recalibrate to see oh this
isn't that rewarding anymore
and there's actually this the
neuroscience of this has been worked out
pretty well there's a part of the brain
called the orbital frontal cortex it
stores and updates reward value I I
think if this is the bbo part of the
brain it's always looking for that
bigger better offer so if we can give
our orbital frontal cortex information
through awareness it gets especially if
we do it in real time it gets accurate
and updated information so accurate
being is when I smoke a cigarette is it
that rewarding no it I didn't realize
it's not that rewarding we can do the
same thing when we overeat we're like Oh
how does my stomach feel right now oh
wait I've wrecked this gut bomb you know
when I did this or even eating you know
I found this with with with gummy worms
like when I would eat gummy worms it was
like I had to just eat the whole bag
because you know I was just gonna be
jonesing for those gummy worms you know
until I just ate it so I started
comparing those to eating blueberries
and blueberries just have this natural
sweetness that's just so much better
than eating gum or so I realized gummy
ones taste like petroleum compared to
blueberries so that came in today with a
with a with a box of blueberries we're
eating when you arrive I'm a big fan of
yeah they're they're great natural
energy so that's the other piece is
seeing giving our brains that bigger
better offer so it can be blueberries
over gummy worms but it can also be
awareness and curiosity over judgment
and that's the piece that can really
help us right in that moment it's not
like we have to look for blueberries to
to you know the blueberry salvation I'm
not peddling like blueberry
enlightenment yeah well a couple
thoughts I mean to to dig a little bit
deeper into your smoking example and
examining the reward taste is one aspect
of it but it's almost an unfortunate
byproduct of what you're really trying
to get out which is that
right that dopamine hit or what whatever
it does do you biochemically in your
brain that gives you a sense of like a
temporary sense of well-being or
enhanced cognition or whatever it is
that nicotine does the taste can be
something you tolerate in order to get
to that other aspect of it which is the
real driver here is it not so the driver
can be the driver again until we bring
awareness to that so if you look at you
know that especially cravings around any
drugs you know alcohol same thing when
we look at what it feels like to be
totally consumed and under the control
of something other than ourselves when
we really pay attention to this it
doesn't feel very good mm-hmm
and so that the dopaminergic Drive it's
associated with restlessness with
agitation with this one pointedness that
says you know you're I'm gonna make your
life miserable until you do this and
then of course as soon as we do it it's
like I'm gonna make your life miserable
until you do it again until you do it
again yeah you're a prisoner of that's
like totally so if we don't pay
attention to what we're actually getting
from that that feeling we don't realize
that this is actually not a good way to
live and that that feeling is very
contracted you know it's it's closed
down and we can actually start to see
well is there something that feels
better than this and if we just take the
binary closed can we find something that
actually is more open so what would you
say feels more open craving or curiosity
well curiosity for sure yeah so if you
think of curiosity in terms of
mindfulness or awareness we can be
totally curiously aware of something
that's happening even in our body right
now and we can flip the valence from
this craving that is all consuming where
we're a prisoner to it - oh wow what
does this actually feel like and
paradoxically we turn toward it and as
we turn toward it and it starts to just
kind of dissolve on its own because it's
oh here's the sensation oh here's the
heat here's rising here's there's this
this we realized this is this is
simply physical sensations that are
driving our lives and then the you know
the gig is up for the for the dopamine
piece yeah it's interesting when you
place your attention on what precisely
it is it tends to dissolve over time and
I've seen this my wife has terrible
migraines over the years and she has a
practice she has a variety of practices
but one of them is to just notice it
like what is it like what is its shape
what is its color where exactly does it
reside in her awareness and the more you
get closer and closer to the essence of
what it is it moves and it changes and
it shifts and it dissipates and I think
I've done the same with cravings as they
arise okay what does this look like
where what is the nature of it what is
the texture of it and the more specific
you can get it tends to lose its pull in
its power
totally totally so that awareness helps
us awake into these physical sensations
that we formerly thought were us but are
actually just physical sensations and
thoughts and we've had people you know
be able to work with panic attacks and
realize oh these are thoughts and these
are body sensations and be able to write
out full-blown panic attacks this way
hmm
so that's you know the theory seems to
be working pretty well we've but again
this is where the soft science and the
hard science comes together I'm not
satisfied with theories or anecdote you
know it's great to see something might
work in somebody's life it's great to
see you know I found tremendous benefit
from mindfulness myself but there's this
joke and research that research has
really me search I don't know if you
heard that yeah yeah so the idea is you
know we're studying something that might
have worked for us and of one but we
don't know that that actually works for
everybody and so you see all these
treatments that are developed based on
the personal experience of wine so I
really wanted to see you know does this
stuff actually stack up you know I had
pretty good results in my in my
addiction clinic but we started doing
research and we our first study was
actually with alcohol and cocaine
dependence and we found that mindfulness
is mindful
training was as good as gold standard
treatment cognitive therapy in this case
for for alcohol and cocaine use
disorders then we moved on to smoking we
found that we could get five times as a
quit rates of gold standard treatment
and at that point we started realizing
wow there's something to this so we
started looking to see well how else
does this work you know and it was
really interesting at the time we were
doing that that work
this is around 2010-2011 I was right
when you know smartphones were starting
to come out and I realized that you know
this process was set up for developing a
context-dependent memory so we remember
where food is so realize well you know
my patients they don't learn to smoke in
my office you know they don't learn to
overeat in my office they don't learn to
get anxious in my office so we started
stepping back and saying we'll wait a
minute could I actually package my
office and bring it to them and we
started developing you know app based
mindfulness training programs and
testing those and we've been found you
know our our eating program that's
called eat right now we got 40 percent
reduction in craving related eating wow
that's amazing yeah and you have what is
it what's the smoking one called it was
called to quit you did you change the
name I was craving to quit original
right now just to to quit okay yeah yeah
three words is to hang out for America's
tensions and you have unwinding anxiety
right yeah I still have that one yeah
you have three three apps for it they're
all they're oriented around the same
perspective and protocols but for
treating these three three kind of
discreet conditions yeah we we figured
that too
you know there are a lot of apps out
there to help people learn to meditate
or learn mindfulness we took a slightly
different approach which was starting
with helping people understand how their
minds work and I think that was a
critical piece because I spent years and
years you know sweating my butt off on
meditation cushions you know I'm silent
retreats just trying to willpower my way
into concentration and just wasn't
working and then it was when all these
things came together where I realized oh
you know the psychologists the
modern-day psychologists they're all
talking about this learning process this
really strong learning process let's
start there
and then you know so we started
incorporating that piece as as an entree
for these for these programs and that's
when things really started to hum you
know we could we we just finished a
study with anxious physicians and got a
close to a 60% reduction in anxiety
symptom
so we're you know with these common
mechanisms that are actually relatively
simple they're straightforward I'm not
saying they're easy to do especially
because we have to overcome some of our
previous biases around you know I'm just
gonna willpower my way through life but
we can help people kind of fall on their
faces a little bit more quickly in terms
of seeing like what is it actually like
when I smoke a cigarette what's it
actually like when I overeat so we we
move away from prescription like okay
valve shouts you know do this this or
this
- well just pay attention and see what
the result of your behavior is remember
as they learn how their mind works they
can start to see that result when they
when that value from the old behavior
drops then we can start to offer them
something new because they're hungry for
they say well this is crappy what else
is there and that's where the curiosity
piece comes in that's where the kindness
piece comes in you know with with our
eating program and our unwitting anxiety
program we saw tons of people who had
these habit loops around self judgment
and shame and blame and all this stuff I
see this with my patients with
addictions as well it's like one of
their number one habit loops oh it's
huge with me I mean it is it's it's it's
such a massive thing because you just
you're like I did it again and the beat
that the cycle of beating yourself up
becomes it sound like you said like its
own addictive loop you know there's
something I have to believe that there's
something about that like that shame
spiral that that is doing something for
me right like I there it's serving some
purpose you know I don't know it's not
you know like I wish it didn't and I
don't know what that purpose is but I
keep doing it so whether there's some
kind of evolutionary imperative to it or
or it's a self to some other wound that
I still need to look at that seems to be
the big piece but but by there's
something
about the curiosity and the paying
attention that that kind of just allows
that to you know slowly evaporate
totally completely but just being
present doesn't give the space for that
judgment to come in or at least there's
a time delay there right well that's
where the attitudinal quality is really
important so curiosity I think of it as
like the other side of the coin of
awareness you know we can be aware and
like this sucks you know or we can be
aware and go oh wow that's interesting
you know what's going on here what's
what's actually happening in my body
what can I learn from this and so we can
take these and we can actually take
moments where we're really struggling
and we can bow to them as a teacher when
we're truly interested in understanding
how our minds work and we can also truly
bow to them as a teacher when we know
that we're gonna learn something
now we're motivated because we're like
well I'm stuck in this right can I can I
actually get some useful information
from this and we can even move from you
know I think of this we always think of
this - you know Stu two steps forward
one step backward one step forward two
steps backward you know if you look at
this if we're learning every time we
fall on our face does that count as
going backwards right to me like we're
always moving forward if we're learning
something because we can't go back when
we've just learned something about
ourselves so even there that attitudinal
quality helps us really keep the
momentum moving forward even if feel if
it feels uncomfortable at the time yeah
that's just a perspective shift like
what lens are you choosing to perceive
this experience through we're kind of
raised to believe that you know we can't
fail or failure is bad I mean it's a
broader conversation about you know
failure in general and and what we
choose to deem in that negative light
but but there's such a relief when you
can kind of let that go but the mental
twist here is that the trying isn't the
path right like in the same way that you
you explained you know your journey
through meditation and like being this
you know
achievement oriented go getting you know
I don't know if you're Taipei but I
would even a lot in your life so you
know you're gonna you're gonna you told
damn like I'm gonna win at meditation
like that kind of mentality which is the
same mentality that that that drives
that intellectual to read all the
self-help books but still remain
prisoner to those behavior patterns so
the learning curve is is not
intellectual but in letting go of that
intellectual exercise and and to get
yourself into that place of allowing
where you can release your attachment to
doing it right or well and just be
present and that is so difficult to to
learn and to really fully croc you know
man it for me being the type a go-getter
you know drive drive drive
I remember being on my first week long
meditation retreat and I remember about
day 3 or 4 I was bawling on the shoulder
of the retreat manager you know didn't
know the woman she seemed nice enough
she landed her shoulder and I just I was
it was a river of tears because I you
know it's like I Princeton I got into
medical school and I can't pay attention
to my breath what is going on here and I
was just I was done you know I was
totally at my wit's end
and she like a she ended up becoming my
teacher for about ten years ended up
being this this amazingly wise teacher I
but I you know I've been trying to
willpower my way through everything and
I figured I well paying attention your
breath that can't be that hard it was
the hardest thing that what does she say
to you did she drop some kind of Yoda
like wisdom suffer you must yeah no I
think she kind of knew I don't remember
what she said but I do know that she
didn't say much
because she kind of knew I just had to
hit bottom and you know I remember being
on another retreat where the the teacher
was so frustrated with me she said well
judge your path to enlightenment is
gonna be through striving because like
she's you know just drive strive strive
strive strive I was just like you're
really good at working hard but she knew
that that wasn't going to be the way
true so you know the the way out
what's that saying the way out is
through mm-hmm I had to go through the
process of trying to willpower my way
through into meditation and and fail and
fail and fail and then wake up and
realize that like you're talking about
it was about letting go and the way for
me to let go was through curiosity and
it started going back to it back to when
I was a kid or when I was in high school
like I was totally fascinated by stuff I
just wanted to see how stuff learned
worked and so I would learn naturally
through simply being curious and I
realized I could actually be curious
here too and it totally flipped my
entire meditation practice I could go
from you know like sweating through
t-shirts trying to meditate to you know
I learned that if you pay attention to
the process and look you know it's
actually in a causal chain that I could
I could be one-pointed for several hours
without any effort at all and that was
to breakthrough serene for me one no
more effort I realized that that is not
the way to go into that it really is
about just bringing these conditions
together and everything will come
together on its own reframing this as
curiosity is is pretty compelling
because linguistics are important and
when you frame it as letting go or
surrender that just you know gets a type
a person's cockles I was like I'm not
gonna I don't surrender you know I don't
let go you know it's like that's not
gonna happen you know I had to be so
beaten down before you know I was even
willing to entertain that what I was
trying to do was not gonna work but just
by kind of tabeling those two words and
replacing them with curiosity is a much
less threatening and inviting way of
approaching all of this
well curiosity itself is rewarding and
so it actually hacks that same system of
you know if we're if we're addicted to
our cell phones we can get curious about
you know what do I get from this mmm-hmm
remember there was a just one example
one of the residue
physicians that was there was training
with me she was in her last year of
residency and she she came in as a
skeptic which is the best type of person
to come in like what is this crap and
how did you actually help people with
addictions are you crazy
so she was you know she was using one of
our apps I don't know if it was our
craving to quit or our eat right now
program and in reading my book and she
woke up to the point where she had two
relatively small kids and was standing
at out away from the dining table like
on a Saturday night her two kids were
eating dinner and she was away from the
table checking her newsfeed and she had
to have that moment where she woke up
and she's like whoa how did it get to
this to the to realize that that she was
under that spell and that's when she got
really curious like oh wow and she
totally got into it had a you know lost
weight she didn't you know a bunch of
things that were kind of just as a
byproduct of her starting to realize her
own habit patterns and wake up right as
somebody who's who's made a lot of
headway in terms of solidifying or
hardening these soft Sciences I want to
talk about what is actually going on in
the brain like the neurology the the
neuroscience of it all because it's
super interesting how you talk about
these different areas of the brain and
how they get activated and what
activates them and how we can adopt
certain practices to you know to get us
on on a better track well I was I've
been fortunate enough to retool when I
was in residency to learn neuroimaging
and neuroscience and so I've been doing
brother
almost two decades now we've been
studying the neuroscience behind how
this stuff works and my lab starts with
finding a behavioral outcome you know we
need to make sure that something's
actually working so you know when we got
five times the court rates of smoking
it was smoking with our with our
mindfulness training or saying okay
there was something there's something
worth looking at here so we started by
looking just looking at experience
versus novice meditators to see what was
happening in their brains and we wanted
to find if there were common mechanisms
that were different with folks that had
practice for a while versus nine so we
actually looked across a bunch of
different types of meditation we had
people pay attention to their breath you
know as a standard concentration
practice we have them do this thing
called loving-kindness which to me was
like the LEAs gooiest nastiest sathyas
you know I was like and I'll tell you a
little bit how it's a great practice it
may be it has a branding problem but it
may I and in my set well maybe give you
a little story about how I actually
learned that in a big but it probably
does have a branding problem and then we
had people do this practice called
choiceless awareness where they would
just pay attention to whatever was
coming into their awareness it could be
sound it could be things that we're
seeing could be things that were feeling
things they were thinking and we found
that there was a brain network called
the default mode network that was
deactivated in experience versus novice
meditators now this was a surprise to me
I think I learned the most when my
hypotheses are disproven you know cuz I
was thinking well I'm working pretty
damn hard so there's got to be some
brain region that's getting activated
that's lighting up when I'm meditating
because you know my spanker tone is
certainly pretty pretty high right now
and you know it turns out that there
wasn't a single brain region that was
increased in activity in experience
versus novice meditators and so I was
like wow how could that be but when we
looked at the opposite when there were
decreases in activity we found that this
default mode network was the own it was
the major difference between experienced
and novice meditators as in their
default mode network got quieter and the
way I think of that is it's kind of like
you're just like you're driving your car
with one foot on the brake and one foot
on the gas if you take your foot off the
brake you don't have to add more energy
into the system but the hard drives
faster and that's exactly what I think
we're seeing with meditation is if we
get out of our own way our brains
naturally work better you know and and
we can really start to totally get in
sync with life and get into you know
almost get into the flow of things so to
speak well let's let's elaborate on this
default mode Network where where is it
in the brain and what is it responsible
for there are a bunch of brain regions
that are involved in the network so we
can we'll just talk about the two main
hubs of the network there's a part
called the prefrontal cortex which is
kind of more in the front of your brain
the medial prefrontal cortex in
particular in midline in the middle and
then there's one called the posterior
cingulate that's and the back and kind
of also midline and those two seem to be
the main hubs of the default one network
and if we don't zoom in on the posterior
cingulate it's an interesting brain
region from an addiction perspective
because it gets activated when people
who are addicted to all sorts of
substances see their substances when
they're triggered so alcohol cocaine
gambling and even even chocolate when
you know one of my friends who's a Food
Research Trail Dana small she did this
study where she would you know feed
people chocolate and they were like this
is great and their posterior saying it
would activate huh interestingly it also
gets activated when she keeps feeding
people and feeding him feeding more and
more and more chocolate and they're like
oh you know what there used to be their
favorite chocolate there now like
heating also activates the posterior
cingulate so it seems to get activated
when we get caught up in like wanting
more but also activated when we get
caught up in wanting less so when
somebody gets caught up in ruminating in
depression for example or perseverating
like worrying about the future also that
brain region gets activated so that that
network seems to be involved in a ton of
self-referential processing so it's
basically you know anything related to
us past future anything related you know
oh that was I can't believe I did that
that was terrible or oh no that might
happen to me that will be terrible
it's why bill and Bob called alcoholism
a disease of self obsession totally and
that's totally rooted in the neuro
chemistry absolutely and we now know the
brain regions associated with
with what they observed experienced so
such a long time ago that's so
fascinating is there is there a
difference in the brain chemistry or the
like the neural makeup of somebody who
is let's say like a substance out of
like cocaine or heroin versus somebody
who who just doesn't have that like
there are people out there that just
they're not triggered by these things in
the way that you know somebody who's an
addict or an alcoholic is there seem to
be some Jeannette there certainly
genetic differences that can predispose
people to addiction versus you know kind
of help people become resilience a or
less predisposed to them I don't think
that there's at least from my
perspective there hasn't been anything
that's like oh this brain region is it I
think it's a very complex picture and
it's going to take a lot of more work
bringing together genetics with you know
the environmental work and whatnot to to
really find things that are that are
reproducible it seems that with
addictions in general that's where the
posterior cingulate seems to be one of
the reliable markers at least from what
we've seen and if you wanted you know I
think this even broadens beyond you know
we've been talking about these classic
addictions but this is where it really
starts to come into the human realm as
in where you know we all have this human
tendency to get caught up right you know
so it could be as simple as getting
caught up in a political view you know
when somebody says oh I disagree with
you and you know and we get we get
closed down and we you know we get this
defensive posture and you know all this
stuff there's that feeling of
contraction that's the same feeling that
comes when we get caught up in a craving
when we want something and when we want
a substance or we want more chocolate or
we want this we want them to agree with
us there's also a loss of our ability to
control our our bodies and the words
that are coming out of our mouths right
like when you get like if you take a
political argument for example it's like
you know you then you're like wait what
did I just do we're not even
like we're not in control and how is
that any different than an addiction
yeah it's not it's in same brain
processes so from that standpoint it
seems that you know it from a
neurobiological standpoint we can see
where there's this common denominator
and it's it's interesting because we've
done we've done some neuro phenomena
logic work which is just a fancy word
where we can link up subjective
experience with brain activity using
real-time neurofeedback we can actually
directly link people's subjective
experience with their brain activity and
this is where it got really interesting
for us so for example when people's
minds are wandering when they're
daydreaming or whatever this default
mode network has been shown to be
activated and when people are
concentrating on a task or when they're
meditating this it gets deactivated
that's what some of our in those studies
that my lab had done but it was like
okay that's interesting but what's
actually going on here and when we
started to line up people's subjective
experience we found something really
interesting which was that they were
they were it was this caught-up quality
when somebody gets caught up in thinking
that's when the default mode network
gets activated when somebody gets caught
up in a craving and we even had some
some really really illuminating moments
where some of these you know like we had
experienced meditators there was a
remember one who said you know I was
trying to meditate harder and somehow
pay attention more and that's when his
posterior seen you as default mode
Network got increased in activity it's
like oh wait a minute this isn't about
trying this isn't about doing yeah that
is that's the trick right that is the
trick this self-obsession
these these stories that we loop in our
minds about who we are
the rehashing of the past the you know
foreshadowing of the future the
catastrophizing all of these things that
we get caught up in this is where it
resides yes and so essentially what
you're saying is meditation
these mindfulness practices are a way of
like lowering the volume on that
and in turn allowing us to then be more
focused more present more curious and
less self judging absolute is that the
most element elementary way of
explaining this yeah yeah and Jon
kabat-zinn who really led the way in a
lot of the scientific you know beginning
of the scientific studies around
mindfulness talks about you know we are
human doings rather than human beings
and that lines up very nicely with this
whole process you know we can we get
stuck in the habit loop of doing if I
just do something here if I'm anxious
I'll just do something to make it go
away if I'm you know I'm gonna do
something to make myself lose weight but
the point that we're missing is that
that doing is another form of addiction
where we get addicted to doing I'm just
gonna do do do do do you know that badge
of honor of I'm busy
cuz I'm doing also guilty of that but we
can wake up to that and ask ourselves
what am I actually getting from this and
again bring that curiosity and look at
that cause-and-effect relationship and
my guess is when we you know I don't
know what what it's like for you but
when you really take perspective and
step back and say well what am I getting
from all this doing a lot of that doing
starts to fall away because it's you
know the doing for doing sake is not
very rewarding well I can come up with a
number of arguments about you know why
I'm doing all the doing but they when
you really examine them they start to
fall apart I mean a lot of the doing is
to distract myself from whatever
emotional state is making me
uncomfortable and the external
validation that I'm chasing that has you
know diminishing returns over time so
you just nailed that diminishing returns
piece that's when we start to see oh
this isn't doing it but the problem is
until we see until we find something
that works more consistently and is
better right that bigger better offer
we're gonna keep doing that and I think
that's where we you know as a society
it's just doo doo doo doo doo until we
pay attention and see the dependency
returns that's when our orbitofrontal
cortex starts see it not as rewarding
but then we start to play with being
whether it's being curious or being kind
or you know those are those are the two
key elements of awareness where we can
just notice right in this moment oh lost
in the past lost in the future what does
this feel like oh not that rewarding
what's it like just to be curious or
what's it like to simply be kind of
myself in this moment and shift from
maybe self-judgement like oh I can't
believe this - oh what's happening in my
body and then that wisdom starts to land
and starts to grow over time we start to
see how wait a minute this isn't doing
it for me it's not doing it for me and
we start to you know sometimes it can
happen quickly
more often and I see this myself and
with my patients we see this more
gradually where you know our brains have
to be totally convinced this isn't gonna
work for us right this old way are you
finding in your studies with all of
these people that that arriving at this
place is becoming more difficult because
we have such a reduced tolerance for any
form of discomfort because we always
have a way to opt out like it seems to
me you know I would be interested in
what's happening with you know teenagers
and young people who don't know what
it's like to ever be without a
smartphone the impact on that on on the
human animals ability to just be present
with one's own discomfort it's hard
because you have to you have to be you
have to in this journey towards being
right you're gonna hurt you're gonna go
through this period of having to be
uncomfortable as you start to you know
figure out how to become curious yeah
right yeah the only way out is through
its it's impossible to know exactly
because we can't you know kind of clone
the human race and then do the parallel
experiment without smartphones but we
can look at how how children adolescents
learn and they learn from modeling you
know and so if they see adults
modeling distractions so if adults are
bored or feeling anxious or whatever and
they're turning to their smartphones
they're gonna model that for the
teenagers as compared to modeling to
stress tolerance or modeling curiosity
and so that's one piece where you know
we can look to see well what are we
modeling for the next generation and
then we can you know I teenagers are
pretty smart and so you know the sooner
they hit rock bottom with the you know
the the job of liking all their friends
posts or whatever and start to break out
of that you know teenagers are
tremendously curious you know they're
exploratory creatures and so I truly
trust that they'll be able to you know
find their ways into this be even better
if we can model this or you know throw
them some bones and say hey you know try
this try this but we can't make them do
anything the more we shake our finger
and especially you know say do this
they're gonna say you know screw this
right and and go the other way one of
the things that you're you're doing in
hardening the soft sciences is these
studies using fMRI right to really look
at this brain activity and people can
watch the 60 minutes where Anderson
Cooper you know goes through this
experience but that was that it eg we
are different right for him but we used
source estimated EEG for that but it's
basically the same same idea right like
let's here you can look at a screen you
can actually see what's happening in the
brain when you're meditating when you're
not meditating and you can quantify it
yeah it's it's pretty remarkable and I
think as a as a hard son growing up as a
hard scientist that being able to
quantify what's actually going on and
Link it to brain mechanisms is pretty
rewarding and it's even more rewarding
when we can link all of these things up
so as a as a clinician scientist the
holy grail for me is having a theory
that lines up with brain mechanism that
lines up with outcomes and so if I can
make the connection between all those
three that's really gratifying for me
because as a clinician you know I don't
want to just learn stuff that's esoteric
and interesting that might you know feed
my own addiction for knowing stuff and
learning stuff but I want to really see
how is this gonna help my patients down
the road or even immediately and so for
example we just finished a study we just
published a study with our smoking
program the to quit program where we we
scanned people we put people in there
from our eye scanner at baseline who
wanted to quit smoking and we show them
a bunch of pictures of smoking cues and
we activated their posterior cingulate
you know like sup like lights up like a
Christmas tree and then we randomized
them to get the to quit program or the
National Cancer Institute's quit guide
so we'd have an act of comparison and
we'd scan them about a month later to
see does change in brain activity
actually predict clinical outcomes and
lo and behold we found that there was a
significant correlation between a
reduction in posterior cingulate
activity and a reduction in cigarettes
only in the to quit program we actually
found a really strong correlation even
with the number of modules they
completed even though both groups
completed the same number of modules so
here we're seeing a dose-dependent
relationship and a brain specific effect
that was affecting clinical outcomes
based on a theory that we had been
exploring you know over a decade before
and so we're able to link up this theory
of mindfulness helps us be with our
cravings and not act on them it affects
this brain network that gets activated
when we're caught up in craving it gets
deactivated with you know with with
mindfulness and here it's affecting
clinical outcomes so that's been really
gratifying to be able to see you know to
be able to live that process you know
we've been doing research now for about
20 years to line all of these things up
it's yeah in a long time coming and walk
me through the exact protocol that you
put these people through yeah like it's
one thing to say be curious write or
meditate but like what is the actual
program so the the craving to quit app
is basically we give them a short
bite-size modules every day so one thing
I learned clinically when we did our
first studies was you know we'd have
people come in once a week to learn this
mindfulness training we'd teach them
mindfulness they'd go home come back a
week later one thing we learned was a
lot of them were struggling with
during the practice is doing the
practicing just setting up the habit to
do it what we know is from habit
formation is you know you need to
knowledge you need to do little steps
and as much as you can do that
consistently so then we graduated to
twice a week and that still wasn't
enough and then we said screw this you
know it threw all that away and said
let's take this manualized
you know evidence-based treatment and
cut it into bite-sized pieces and
deliver it through people's phones and
so that's where we can actually move
from you know in the office to in
context right right it goes back to the
people don't learn to smoke in my office
so with the apps we can actually deliver
ten minutes of training every day you
know where they really learn the the
practices importantly they start with
helping them understand how their mind
works so we basically show them the
habit loop help them start to identify
you know okay what triggered smoking
what do I get from smoking and
importantly we have them pay attention
as they smoke that's the first step and
start to really pay attention to what do
I get from this what do I get from this
what do I get from this
so that reward value starts to drop then
we give them an exercise and all this is
all you know automate it through the app
where when they have a craving they can
click on that craving button and they
can actually imagine smoking a cigarette
so we walk them through okay you light
it up what does What's it feel like when
it goes in your mouth what's it taste
like what's it smell like afterwards
what does your body feel like and that
can give them a gauge to how
disenchanted they are with the smoking
right how much is that reward value
dropped and if it hasn't dropped in the
past it helps them really pay attention
to see how much that engenders a craving
and if it doesn't gender a craving then
we have them smoke mindfully and go
through that smoking mindful exercise so
that it lays down that new reward value
that says oh how good was this and as
they repeat that over time that's when
they can start to move from smoking
mindfully laying down that new reward
value and then just moving to imagining
smoking and then when they win that
reward values drop when they imagine
doing it if their bodies like why would
you do this and actually look you know
this this occurred to me when I was on a
plane
was actually on a plane to fly out to
California a little while ago and I was
offered the airplane food and I went
through this simulation in my mind I was
like do I want the food and I imagine
eating it like that process crap so I
realized I was like wait a minute we can
actually turn this into an exercise that
will capture whether somebody is
disenchanted with the behavior or not so
we do this with our smoking probably we
do this with our eating program and if
it if it if they're not disenchanted yet
that's fine
we have them go into the into the actual
EM experience so smoke or eat or
whatever so they can start to build that
disenchantment so as they go through the
program you know it's 20 30 modules as
they go through this they can build that
disenchantment in their direct
experience mmm I would imagine you can
if you can master that practice it
becomes applicable not just in smoking
or airplane food but almost in every
situation you could use it to do I want
to you know say yes to this opportunity
do I want to you know do I want to go to
this place like all you know you could
run that calculus for anything
absolutely so this is where I this is
like the the the stealth of this
practice is you know as we learn
something you know if you think of
knowledge you can learn knowledge about
one thing like okay this is how this
thing works
but if you develop wisdom you start to
see oh this works in the same way as
this as this as this is this in this and
we start to develop this wisdom around
life where we're like wait a minute
this is how my mind works as compared to
oh this is how I work with eating or
smoking or anxiety this is on my wine
work so I can actually apply this to
relationships I can apply this to this
for example I had a guy in our who'd
come in for alcohol treatment and he was
this really big muscular mechanic you
know he'd come in it's hard to get oil
off your hands after working you know
working in an engine all day so he'd
come in having tried to wash his hands
but still you know pretty
pretty gritty and at the end of the
program I asked him what was your what
was your favorite aspect of this and he
gave me this sheepish grin and he said
you know I've actually changed my
relationship with my dad this program
has taught me to actually work with that
and realize that you know this is the
loving-kindness practice for him which
is the you know the last thing I thought
he was gonna say but he had generalized
this knowledge of working with with
using mindfulness to work with drinking
to changing his lifelong relationship
with his dad mmm I would imagine on some
level that gets to the underlying
impetus for a lot of addictive behavior
right like I'm interested in how your
work squares with like let's say gab or
Matta and all the work that he's done
with impact of childhood trauma on how
you know these behaviors manifest later
in life or Johann Hari and you know his
thesis on lost connection and how this
is really an epidemic of connectivity
among human beings
I think it's squares perfectly I was
just to spend some time with Gabor a
little while ago at a conference and we
were really you know just it's so fun to
geek out about this stuff with with with
folks and it's totally it makes complete
sense if you think about you know loss
of connection for example so we feel
lonely that's the trigger we do
something like drink or drug and then we
basically numb ourselves to that pain so
it's as temporizing measure we get this
brief relief and then we have to repeat
it so if we never get at the heart of
the issue which is you know the
disconnection we're always going to feed
it in a way that's not healthy so here
we can you know mindfulness can help us
wake up to those patterns and see how
we're feeding these in very unhealthy
ways and then open ourselves to finding
different ways of relating right smoking
drinking you know these behaviors are
you we do them because they work right
like their respect
we work while they work until they stop
working they're serving it they're
serving it they're filling a need
they're serving a purpose yeah that
works for a period of time until it
until it stops working but they're not
necessarily the problem they're like the
solution to the problem there are like a
bandaid on the problem right so you're
dealing with this condition at the
behavioral tip of the spear someone like
at war is dealing with this at it's at
its inception point right where it where
it begins and and so I would imagine
that on some level a combination of
these two approaches would be you know
the comprehensive solution here like you
got to deal with you got to quit smoking
you got to break this cycle of craving
you got to create you know strategies
and behavior patterns for for managing
this but you still also have to go to
the root of like what is you know
creating this level of discomfort to
begin with or what is it that continues
to creep up and makes you feel
uncomfortable in your own skin driving
that need to escape out of whatever it
is you're experiencing through whatever
behavior that you're choosing yeah
absolutely and in the moment you know in
the moment that we are uncomfortable if
we can learn to be a little more
embracing of that discomfort it can help
us open to seeing where we've you know
where that heart of the problem and you
know oh it where we haven't been willing
to look at disconnection or willing to
look at you know all this stuff that can
just keep feeding it because it's just
been too painful and then we've trained
ourselves to numb ourselves when we can
train ourselves to actually be with that
discomfort that opens up the possibility
for true and deep healing mm-hmm and how
does all of this square with traditional
12-step approaches I think it works
beautifully you know there's a there's a
book called one breath at a time I don't
know if you're familiar with it but the
guy lies lays out that how all the 12
steps line up very beautifully with with
Buddhism and mindfulness practice yeah
you know the step wine I am not in
control wait a minute willpower doesn't
work you know so
you know and you just go on and on and
on with each of the steps and there's
there's nothing that's that's
discontinuous or at odds between these
that's one thing I like about it
mindfulness practice is it's not about
some big philosophy or you know you must
do a bunch of things
it basically distills down to pay
attention see what the results of your
behavior are repeat and that can that
can work with any spiritual tradition
and it can work with the twelve steps
and I think it can enhance a lot of work
that people are really struggling with
you know a number of patients who go
through his 12 steps and it takes them a
long time to get through you know
there's some steps that are just really
really tough that they were just like
wow not ready for this doesn't have to
but it tends to people get hung up on
around four and then there's a very
protracted long period of time before I
was thinking of more in particular and I
agree it doesn't have to especially if
we can build up the ability to be with
our own discomfort that's when it can
help us see for as a strength rather
than as a big barriers like oh god I got
to do this as in oh here we go you know
let's do this rather than being afraid
of confronting those difficult complex
emotions being curious about them yeah
can open up that door yeah and then of
course the word meditation appears in
the state it doesn't get traditionally
it's sort of the bastard stepchild like
it doesn't really get the treatment or
attention that it deserves but there's
nothing about it that says that it
shouldn't yeah yeah and you can look it
so let's take fear for example on a very
experiential level what we were finding
is it goes back to the neuroimaging work
that we were doing we can actually we're
finding that this contracted or closed
down quality of experience correlates
with increased activity in the posterior
cingulate cortex cortex and that's open
experience correlates with decreased
activity and so on a very basic level we
can help people really pay attention to
what is you know just pay attention to
that closed feeling when you're afraid
and bring curiosity to that and it
starts to open that piece right right in
that moment and so we can really bring
that curiosity and kindness in as a as a
way to directly you know clean out that
wound in those moments where people are
really struggling with say the fourth
step or whatever from what I gather from
your work it doesn't seem to matter that
much what type of technique you decide
to adopt meditation technique yeah I
think I've practiced a ton of different
techniques and I was a technique junkie
for a while because I was thinking you
know I got just find the perfect
technique mm-hm and then I realized I
was asking the wrong question it's it's
different you know different techniques
work for different people and so it's
important that people find a technique
that they can really resonate with but
underlying all of these techniques is
this you know am i working am i closing
am i clenching am i forcing verses am i
resting and resting and awareness
because these practices share this
common underlying element of awareness
itself and that attitudinal quality of
curiosity so there's no evidence from
like an fmri perspective like Oh
loving-kindness does this and vasana
does this and you know can you can you
calibrate them in that way when we've
looked we found that you know loving
kindness that Vipassana that
concentration practice is that a bunch
of different we've even done some pilot
work with with christian and
contemplative practice all of them share
this core element of letting go you know
whether and the language might be
slightly different but the letting go is
the same you know and whether it's
letting go into concentration letting go
into just noticing the changing nature
of reality and if I pass on to practice
whether it's letting go of the small
self and letting God flow through you in
christian contemplative practices all of
these share that common element and we
and we see that shared element in fMRI
prac in fMRI studies what is the most
counterintuitive or surprising thing
that you
learned about this whole world as a
neuroscientist like did you go I would
imagine you go in you're trying to be
objective but you're like oh this is
gonna prove this right and then you
discover oh my god it's not that way at
all yeah I mean how much time do we have
there were we there are a lot of things
that were really surprising I think the
biggest surprise was the one I mentioned
earlier around this wasn't about doing
something this was about I'm really just
relaxing and letting letting things be
and there was a you know actually even
more surprising to me was the what I'm
gonna describe as the causal nature of
these things and this related to
everything from concentration practice
to even finding flow where there there's
this you know the Buddhists they have
they're famous for lists you know yeah
for this very good at the 8th this
whatever so they have this list of these
7 factors of awakening
sounds like a pretty important list to
pay attention to i'd always tried to
memorize the list and could never do it
you know it's these seven things i can't
remember i can only learn things if i
understand why they work and it occurred
to me after years probably my teachers
beating their heads against the wall
they come on god i'm that this list goes
in a particular order and it starts with
awareness and basically curiosity or
dumb of a taya means like in interest or
kind of exploration you know like
investigation and so if we if we pay
attention something and we get curious
about and we investigate it what they
describe is the third factor of awaking
naturally coming as a result of those
first two where a Veria can be
translated as courageous energy so we
actually when you're curious about
something or when i'm curious about
something i actually wanna lean i get
energized like wow wow you know it's
like reading a good book
you know we're tired late at night but
we start reading good book and like wow
it's 3:00 in the morning how that you
know and we had all this energy to read
so this actually leads to this fourth
factor of awakening which is joy or
rapture which then leads to tranquility
and then concentration so i've been
doing this all wrong in my own practice
and I also studying this in a way where
I was thinking we're gonna find that
forced part of the brain you know part
of the brain that's that's gonna be
involved in meditation well there wasn't
anything as I mentioned that they get
got increased in activity but it was
that decrease when we started to let go
that concentration naturally emerges out
of these conditions when we're
interested in something and we're
curious and we're not forcing anything
when we're tranquil it actually is
rewarding in itself and so it's a
feed-forward mechanism that winds up
beautifully with operant conditioning
remember reward it feels good that the
concentration naturally emerges out of
these conditions and in itself feels
pretty good so when we're totally
consonant concentrated in something it
feels great and when we're really
concentrated on something we totally
lose a sense of ourselves and we start
to merge with the rest of the world and
we'd even seen this in experienced
meditators there's this concept I'm you
know it well I'm sure flow no you know
me I took some oh hi talks about flow in
terms of being selfless it's effortless
its joyful you know it's like this this
thing a lot of extreme athletes really
they'll die for and seen this a lot you
know there's some great books written
about how dangerous it is for for
athletes to get addicted to flow we had
people in our fMRI scanner getting into
flow and reporting on it we've got a
snapshot of their brains as their
posterior cingulate took a nosedive in
activity just totally quieted down as
they were merging with their environment
and if you think about it this there's
closed quality of experience this
contracted quality is a marker of okay
I'm here and the rest of the world is
out there well when that starts
expanding when you take that to infinity
where do you end and where does the rest
of the world begin so we're gone stuff
is happening it's no effort and we're
totally dialed in and in the brain all
of those levels are going there's no
area of the brain that's being activated
by this it's just a d volume ization of
every component open mind I would say we
only looked specifically at the
posterior cingulate cortex
so these self-referential brain regions
are getting really hard it's responsible
for that yeah given that's super
interesting so given that addiction is a
condition of self obsession the more
self-obsessed we are the more imprisoned
we are by these cravings and desires the
dissolution of that that myth of
differentiation is part of the path that
walks you towards this solution so I'm
curious about your thoughts when it
comes to things like ayahuasca and
psychedelics like these are substances
that that dissolve that illusion of self
and allow us to like merge with this you
know to be at one with the universe and
there's certainly interesting studies
that are that are happening right now in
this field like where where's your head
with all that I'm glad you asked that
question because it's a really
burgeoning field of science and
serendipitously when we published our
first big finding with experienced
meditators where we found the default
mode network was deactivated two months
later in the very same journal the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences this group from London led by
David Nutt and Robin card Harris
published their first study with
psilocybin so the the active ingredient
in magic mushrooms and they found
basically to achieve the same two main
hubs of the default mode network were
really quiet and I immediately contacted
them and said dude this cannot be a
coincidence
they said dude this cannot be a
coincidence and so that started the road
down exploring you know what are the
similarities here and there's you know
roland griffiths at johns hopkins has
really led the way in the u.s. with this
research looking at experienced
meditators and you know help using
things like psilocybin to help people
with addictive disorders the way I think
about this you know to the point where
Michael Pollan wrote a great book -
nobody's talking about this book yeah so
he actually came in and visited my lab
we had him do get into our neurofeedback
rig and just remember a time when he had
done a psychedelic remember a
psychedelic experience and that memory
could put him into the feeling of what
it was like to let go and we could see
the corresponding reduction in brain
activity in his posterior cingulate
cortex which was pretty trippy like
literally but also fits very
interestingly with what the you know
this translation of mindfulness the
ancient word for it is sati which means
to remember so many people translate you
know or interpret what that means you
know to remember to be in the present
moment or you know to me it's a lot
related to well remember what happened
when you did this last time you know do
you really want to go there again as
were being in the present moment
recalling what happened previously so he
recalled what happened previously and he
was reliving you know this this trip
that was actually manifesting in real
time in reduction in his brain activity
was pretty far out so how does this how
do you foresee this field playing out
well if I had a crystal ball that
actually worked I mean I I guess my
perspective is I'm super interested I
mean there's there's amazing things that
are happening in the world right now to
the extent that anybody can come up with
productive solutions to help heal people
that suffer I'm completely supportive of
that at the same time as somebody who
you know is very much an addict and an
alcoholic in recovery for many years you
know my like talk about like you know my
default node Network like firing like
here's my solution I just need to do
more drugs this is the path that I need
to be on yeah like and then I and then I
have to then be curious about what
that's about like what is driving that
compulsion yeah so realizing that
there's an unhealthy aspect to that as
well absolutely so I think there are two
pieces here the
first one is if people don't know or
can't remember what it's like to let go
it's pretty challenging to train them in
that direction so we can use things like
neurofeedback we can use things like our
app based mindfulness training programs
to help people really see what it's like
to get contracted and then identify
moments when they're letting go and I
think that's also where where we can
bring together things like digital
therapeutics and and psilocybin and
other psychedelics where you can you
know in a in a very careful way help
people you know taste what it's like to
let go with a psychedelic mmm and really
help them integrate that experience with
feedback training with direct experience
from their own life so we can say okay
you just have this you know we just did
this the assessing session with you
really zoom in on what it's like to be
contracted versus letting go that can
kind of give them that guiding star to
say okay now as you go throughout your
life we're gonna train you to notice
moments when you're moving away from
that when you're getting closed down and
notice moments when you're moving toward
it when you're opening up and
importantly we can train you to link
those two things up so again learning
through reward based learning we learn
from cause-and-effect so if we can see
the cause of when we get contracted and
we can see how painful it is it can help
our brain reduce that the tendency to go
there in the future if we can notice
moments when we're open like when we're
curious or when we're kind we can see
really pay attention and say oh what was
that like and our brain says oh that was
good I want to do that again so we can
really pair the two give them that
guiding star where they might not have
had that before or remembered it and
then train them to do that over and over
and over yeah a big part of me managing
my addictions is being part of a
community to which I'm accountable and
I'm interested in and if there's any
Studies on the neuro chemistry of what
happens to our brains when we feel you
integrated in a group of people that
care about us that we know are looking
out for us and conversely what happens
when were of service to others right I
would imagine that there's a curiosity
component to that there's an in there's
there's sort of a an engagement that
occurs that that that allows us to
transcend our self obsession and invest
ourselves in other people that is a huge
part of my you know solution but I'm
interested in the scientific kind of
lens on that yeah yeah absolutely we're
actually starting to collect so we I
think that community is a really
critical component and we've actually
built very carefully curated online
communities for the program people in
our programs so for example to eat right
now programming of this large community
the unwinding anxiety program large
community so we can actually start to
look at their direct experience in
relationship to themselves as they
progress through the program and as they
keep you know a lot of people will keep
a journal in the community and support
each other and learn from each other
that way it's got to be a huge part of
long-term success I mean if you don't
have that in place you might get great
results over 30 60-day 90-day period but
it's gonna start to fall off it that
could absolutely be the case and I think
we can also do this experiment so I
actually wrote a whole chapter in my
book around this around you know what's
it like when were mean versus nice for
example and we can look at generosity
for example being service being of
service from a simple lens of reward
based learning so if we see somebody in
need and we help them and we truly help
them in a selfless way where we're not
looking for them to thank us so we're
not looking to be able to tell our
friends like I helped this person but we
just truly we see somebody need we help
them we can notice what that reward
feels like it's clean it's energizing
it's not depleting which is completely
different from the martyr who's like you
know and we see this in health care you
know the physicians and clinicians like
oh I gotta help everybody
god help everybody and when we're not
actually doing that from a healthy place
we get burnt out we get deplete it and
so we can all do this experiment ourself
and see what is it like when we're truly
doing service for services sake not when
we're depleted but when we're really at
the place to do that and that's
different you know we can't say oh I I
should go out and be generous because
it's gonna help me mm-hmm yeah that's
that's dead on arrival but it's truly
like when we're at the place when we can
do service and in it's important when we
can we you know to be there because
often we think oh you know I'm being
selfish by taking care of myself well
that's not true we're not separate from
our society if we're not helping
ourselves we're not actually going to be
able to help others as well so we really
have to be at that foundational level to
be able to be of service and then when
we just explore what's it like when I do
service when I'm of service to others we
can see is it actually energizing or
depleting and then it starts to feed
forward I think there's also a placebo
effect with that in the sense that if I
not to play devil's advocate but but I
think that I Devils that I think that
even if my service action is motivated
by selfish reasons like let's say I'm
you know I'm having a bad day I'm just
I'm throwing a pity party for myself
things aren't going right I'm I'm fully
invested in myself obsession I do still
have enough self-awareness to say I know
that's why I'm suffering and you know
what I should do right now I should just
call somebody up who is having who I
know is having a worse time than me and
just ask them how they're doing like a
small gesture I'm not going to a soup
kitchen or something like that but it's
a way to break that cycle of self
obsession and interrupt that kind of
thought pattern that's looping in my
head and just momentarily invest myself
and somebody else's well-being and that
interruption
even when motivated purely by selfish
reasons like I'm not you know some white
knight you know who's purely doing it
for you know for reasons I wish you know
we're motivating me it still has the
same effect like I will feel better it
is interrupted that I feel good because
I know that I that I you know made
myself available even when I'm busy for
somebody else and that's a practice that
is you know served me well over many
years yes I don't think that's in
Congress at all if you look at it as I'm
gonna help somebody in order to feel
better then that can loop in a negative
way but what you pointed out was two
things one awareness you're self aware
of this is a habit pattern that I'm
stuck in and I can do this to step out
of it that's absolutely skillful as
compared to I'm gonna perpetuate the
cycle of I have to be helping people for
me to have self-worth mmm right so
that's the big difference is you're
helping yourself step out of the cycle
as compared to perpetuating a cycle
that's unhealthy right what are the
things that that trip people up the most
like let's take quitting smoking for
example like even they come to you
they're like I get it Judd I'm in like
tell me what to do I'm doing it I got
the app and the whole thing but they're
still like oh I thought I was clear but
you're still doing that thing yeah we
used this this analogy so big fan of
riding bicycles so we actually came up
with this gears analogy and first gear
is about noticing our habit loops right
if we can't move notice then we can't
move at all we're always moving
backwards second gear is exploring what
the result is like what do I get from
this and that's a really critical step
that people try to bypass as much as
they can because intellectually they
know you know smoking or overeating it's
you know I know it's not good for me and
they want to jump right to third eye to
the end yeah yeah so third gear is when
we're actually stepping out of the loop
so we're being kind
we're being curious we're using these
mindfulness practice this is to actually
step out of these old habitual behaviors
so what I see most is people trying to
jam it from thirst and a first and a
third gear and of course you know they
right they it doesn't work you know
you're on a hill and for you
however on the bike are installed a call
yeah yeah yeah so you have to just
embrace the process as its laid out yeah
in front of you yeah and the second the
second step or that second gear is the
most illuminating because that's really
where our brain starts to shift from
these unhealthy behaviors seeing that oh
this isn't rewarding to finding the
motivation to look for something higher
and that's where that's when we can
actually shift into third gear it's it's
not glamorous but it's quite cool what
is the research that has not been done
yet that you would like to see be done
that could shed additional light on the
craving mind oh boy there's a lot one of
the pieces that we're working on now is
really lining up the specific mechanisms
around the people doing these mental
imagery exercise or not imagery but kind
of these mental imagination exercises
where they imagine going and eating
overeating or imagine smoking in lining
that directly up with the with the
change in reward value in their brain so
we've only done you know we've done some
nura mijung work with smoking but we
want to see this also in the eating
program we want to see this even with
anxiety and I think it's really
important to show that we can across
different types of behaviors that
there's a common underlying mechanism we
see this behaviorally where we can see
these you know strong results was
smoking with eating anxiety I want to
also see that this is true
neurobiologically because that helps us
line up these mechanisms in a more sound
manner I mean we see this clinically we
see this behaviorally but there's
something that would be really nice to
be able to say look here's a general
generalizable even scientific concept
that applies to what the true underlying
mechanisms of mindfulness actually are
mmm so the craving mind your book it's
an interesting story that got you here
right like this was a furious product of
a self-imposed home retreat yes yeah I
mean did you ever doubt it
like the power of meditation and
mindfulness practices in terms of
unleashing your inner creative you know
fire like you're the poster boy yeah
that was it that was an interesting
experiment so a couple of years before I
wrote the book I remember waking up one
Saturday morning and I was just you know
I've been thinking through this concept
of lining up reward-based learning with
these you know these seven factors of
awakening whatnot for a while and one
morning I just was a Saturday morning I
can remember what the temperature was
outside that it was partly cloudy all
this stuff I just went down to my dining
room table pulled out a couple of
references and watched this paper write
itself in three hours and I put that and
you close my laptop like wow that was
amazing what was that and the paper got
published without with very few
revisions you know whatnot oh wow I can
actually you know I've been I've been
learning to get into flow through like
mountain biking and playing music and
whatnot I was like wow I can actually do
this when writing so fast forward
several years I when the book felt like
it was ready to be written and that was
actually a critical piece I can't just
like say hey I'm gonna write about you
know cooking and sit down and write a
cook I'm you know I don't know how to
did pester to write a book for a while
right I had business yeah so you know
several publishers is hey we'd like you
to write a book this and that and it
just hadn't felt right and so I kind of
been like oh someday I'll do it someday
and then finally the conditions came
together and so I did it as a as a
experiment as a meditation retreat so I
my wife it was over the holidays so as a
my wife went off to spend time with her
family for the for the holidays and so I
was it was just myself at her house with
the cats and so I decided to do a self
retreat so I'd done month-long self
retreats before at home which is really
good practice because like every
distraction is there but this one I
decided I said I would just do I would
sit walk and write as in you know
regular sitting and walking meditation
and I would write only when I felt
totally in flow like
vandals like it was just coming out and
so I'd sit down and write and write and
then as soon as it started to feel
contracted I would close the computer
and just sit and walk and it was really
interesting because I wouldn't even like
the thinking wouldn't even come up about
the writing it would just sit and walk
and then I would get up then remember
this one point where I was like and then
I you know rest of the day sit walk sit
walk and then I got up the next morning
I was like cool and this whole chapter
came out Wow
so basically two weeks you know a
two-week retreat and in the book was
written that's unbelievable it was
really fun and it contravenes but this
sort of Steven Pressfield war of art
like shell for the page every day no
matter what like push through like you
are in this is more of a surrender like
in allowing like I'm just allowing this
to happen and the minute it feels
constricted to use your word you walk
away from it without any judgement
absolutely and I think that book
experience was a really good reminder
that we can actually train ourselves to
live our lives this way each moment yeah
each moment we can be looking Oh did
rich asked me did I answer Rich's
question well oh that was a crazy do we
have to be two decades into our
meditation practice to avail ourselves
of this us we don't so one thing that I
want to do to be of service it's you
know I've fallen in my face a lot you
know it was over ten years that I would
you know struggle and struggle and
struggle with meditation before I
started to wake up that it wasn't about
the struggle and the struggle taught me
something so one thing I want to do to
be of service is to help other people
like learn that they don't have to the
struggle is not it you can learn from
the struggle but the struggle is not it
and so we you know that's why we set up
our that's why I do this research to
really try to understand what are the
mechanisms what are the most efficient
ways to deliver this this is why this
turned you know we started developing
apps I had no idea me making app based
trainings but the aim was can we deliver
this in a way that is as efficient and
as helpful as possible and I think you
know we can use these weapons of mass
traction our cellphones in a way that
can actually be helpful if people are
already you know if they already have
these things and are using them
ubiquitously why not use them as a way
to help us train our lives and then we
can learn that the cell phones the
technology is not the problem it's that
we don't know how our minds work and we
can start to learn to work with our my
yes our relationship to them you wrote
an interesting piece where you talk
about the I mean there's a lot of sort
of self-help apps out there that are
oriented around losing weight or you
know what what have you but you kind of
canvas the the efficacy of these things
and it was something like they purport
to be for the most part something like
70% efficacious but in fact only two
percent effective two point six or
something like that yeah basically
there's very very very little science
behind any of these things and there are
a lot of folks that claim Oh based on
science well that's mean yeah exactly
what does that mean and when you dig
into it and people have done Studies on
this when they've dug into it it doesn't
mean a whole lot for most of these so
hopefully the field will actually mature
where there will be good science behind
these things but it takes years and it
actually takes interest in doing that
and a lot of companies don't have that
much time to survive they've got this
clock taking this this runway that's
gonna run out if they don't sell a
product fortunately you know we were one
of the homegrown where I really want to
understand mechanism I would really want
to make sure something works you know
and if if we can put it out there and
help people great but I'm not gonna base
this on you know we've got a you know
10x are whatever yeah and this is this
is like consumer facing but it's also
used for like enterprises right like
you're using us with with just
corporations and health care company any
like companies that want to make sure
that their employees are you know
mindfully healthy yeah well I think
companies are finally waking up to the
fact that they you know it costed a lot
of money it costed a lot of productivity
and it's so gratifying
to see that companies are actually
looking at the well-being of their
employees you know that used to be in
the soft side of HR was like oh well
being yeah we'll throw a little money at
that to say that we're doing this
they're really saying well you know
well-being is actually a critical
element to our employee you know to
keeping employees here long-term you
know the reducing turnover and all this
stuff so I think they're really starting
to look at this much more carefully to
say you know where are the
scientifically based programs that can
actually move the needle for us and so
we've started to you know we've been
getting a lot of incoming traffic where
companies are very interested in in
seeing this because you know we've been
doing the science but 20 years it's got
to be really gratifying for you as
somebody who's been in this for so long
to see the culture kind of catch up with
where you've been at for some time and
really embrace these ideas in a
mainstream way yeah yeah going from boy
Jed you're gonna kill your career yeah -
whose have you called that guy recently
you're like hey yeah 18 million on my
TED talk dude well I sent him a postcard
yeah yeah well that on the TED
Conference of course the the e I know
how ungratified ego gratification
actually play that one out like alright
well it feels good for a minute and then
the hangover afterwards of like oh man
it I said it like it yeah I know but I
can at least propose it it's a good
thought experiment we got to wrap this
up here but I want to kind of close this
with some just practical wisdom on
meditation I loved everything that that
you had to say about the letting go and
the allowing and and and trying to get
into that place of letting go of all the
self judgment and and the willing of the
process to be something other than it is
right this battle like I'm gonna be a
good meditator I'm gonna sit here until
I conquer my my thinking my god damnit
you know as being like absolutely the
wrong path and it's so difficult I think
that is the biggest kind of conventional
wisdom hurdle that people need to
overcome to just embrace this process
and show up for
for you know for what it is absolutely
that is that is number one
you know let's move beyond willpower you
know it's had 50 years of stuff let's
say let's move on to really
understanding how our minds work and I
think we're way past being able to do
that yeah and the first if somebody's
listening to this and they they're
they're caught in well let me just back
up and say if you're listening to this
and you know you don't identify as
somebody who's an addict in the
traditional sense I would encourage all
of you to think more objectively and and
really do you know do an analysis a
forensic analysis on how you live your
life every single day and I don't think
there's anybody out there who who won't
be able to you know see and identify
some behavior pattern whether it's a
tendency to get into a certain kind of
relationship or a certain kind of social
dynamic that you perpetuate despite you
know negative outcomes there is always
something that can be pinpointed that
needs a little redress and I think you
know what Joe does shared today can be
instrumental and helpful in helping you
understand a that you're doing that and
be that there is a path forward that can
allow you to ultimately transcend it
amen brother yeah and it begins with
what awareness awareness and this if
somebody doesn't know what awareness is
though like what do you mean by that I
mean paying attention like really being
truly awake in the present moment and
importantly not being pushed or pulled
by our biases you know you know colored
by oh this is the way the world works
but really being colored by curiosity
like oh is this the way the world work
is this actually true so that we're
observing what's actually happening
rather than what we think should be or
want to be happening hmm so difference
between curiosity and listening I think
we can listen
curiously or we can listen in a biased
manner so if we're listening waiting to
hear a certain thing or hearing things a
certain way
yeah and I'm sure we've all experienced
this we're like oh I thought I heard
this and somebody said no I said that so
we can listen but if we're I would think
I would say this is somewhat synonymous
with deep listening where we are totally
out of our own way and we are just
totally in the process of listening
that's you know that curiosity piece and
the awareness piece and even flow we
really just so engrossed in a
conversation that's totally synonymous
all right I think that's a good place to
land the plane how do you feel oh great
are you craving anything right now no
idea I went this long Wow two hours is
good the book is the creating mind it's
a great book I'm well into it at this
point I highly recommend everybody check
it out there's so much good stuff in
here plus an amazing foreword by Jon
kabat-zinn which is beautiful and if
people want to learn more about you dr.
jicama what's the best place for them to
go yeah we've got a that's our resource
website dear Ju decom where they can
learn about my research about the book
about our apps and we've got a bunch of
animations on there that teach people
like everyday addictions and things like
that right all the apps can be found
through that that portal yeah absolutely
and check out his TED talks right you've
got to - well Ted and the TEDx and a big
Ted yeah how many views does that thing
have now I'm crazy number of you a lot
yeah all right you don't want to admit
that you check once in a while man come
back in and share with me more I love
what you're doing I appreciate the work
that you're doing I think it's really
important you know addiction is the
epidemic of our time it's why we're
obese it's why the opioid crisis exists
these are massive problems that need to
be solved at scale and so the science
that you're doing and how it merges with
these traditional historic methods
of mindfulness I think is super
important and worth everybody's
conscious investigation so thank you
thank you
alright peace plants
you